hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to kyle is famous
congratulations kyle you finally made it
the freeze frame like
yeah
[Music]
so this is a interactive game with 117
endings supposedly
so
kyle woke up he is famous he is
famous
kyle is host of the most popular talk
show in recent memory stay up late with
kyle great
stay up late with kyle has grown in
popularity quickly in the last year and
the public has noticed great
inside has called kyle a most excellent
dumpy white man great
top tech noted that kyle is inspiring
youth to explore stem fields great most
other talk shows are dedicated to
discussing kyle and his personal details
that one's not as great but still great
most online videos are best of clips
taken from kyle's latest broadcast right
the eye of the world is upon kyle
intimidating for kyle tonight is kyle's
most important guest interview yet tell
me why stay up late with kyle we'll be
featuring rachel may she is a kind and
lovely philanthropist okay
she is dear to the hearts of many this
interview requires preparation okay kyle
cracked his eyes open knowing today is
his last chance to prepare for the
interview
kyle has 30 hours left he must choose
his actions wisely i see so we are
picking kyle's life for him to prepare
for this interview oh kyle's first
decision of the morning was made wisely
i know this probably is an instant game
over but
kyle decided to stay put and wither away
kyle withered successfully and died
[Laughter]
all right shucks kyle is now a ghost
this does not relieve him of his
responsibility oh i thought oh okay get
out of bed anyway kyle exited his bed
and took a quick glance around his
bedroom scavenge
scavenge kyle quickly crouched down on
the floor realizing his immediate need
for
bug nah bugs are gross gossip
kyle firmly pressed his ear into the
carpet hoping to hear some stray words
from the neighbors below but aren't i a
ghost couldn't oh my god i'm a ghost
okay i heard rachel may is going on a
trip out of the country soon oh
girlfriend tell me more
okay
well what i will tell you is that every
night i don a mask that looks like a bug
and fight miss doers
okay well that is not as helpful as the
previous statement
there was a stunned silence then a door
opened and someone exited the neighbor's
apartment
okay how did that take eight hours
i'll return to the center of the bedroom
um i guess i'll go
kyle walked into the small hallway that
connected the rooms of his apartments
together check the lock door why do i
have a locked door
i walked over to the strange door in the
hallway but found quickly that the door
was locked from the inside
forced
yeah i mean yeah well float through as a
ghost oh hell yeah kyle used his ghostly
powers to walk straight through the door
i am surprisingly good at this game
kyle found himself in the room he
stashed with by the various items sent
to him by fans check the sewing machine
kyle walked over to the dilapidated
sewing machine its box was only half
removed
okay
great
what does that mean
all right kitchen
uh check pantry kyle wanted to access
the pantry but found it was locked with
a small keyhole float through it ah fine
i won't
kyle opened the fridge intending to find
something to eat
kyle pointed his neck directly upwards
and hoisted the fridge on top of his
face
okay somehow miraculously he wrapped his
mouth around the device he started to
swallow oh
in one slow horrible movement the fridge
slid down kyle's throat i mean i am a
ghost so
after many gurgles pops and snaps kyle
felt relatively sure the fridge would
not come back out okay so i had bad food
great that's great
that's great i'm gonna go back to the
hallway
i'm gonna leave
walked out into the middle of the road
and took a long pondering look around
him downstairs neighbor tech store
uh tech store
techno gym an elaborate cutout mascot
playing soft music from a small
microphone
[Music]
yeah i'll steal techno gym quickly
before the attendant could acknowledge
him kyle grabbed techno gym by the
shoulders more
finding the techno gym's cardboard feet
were bolted to the ground kyle started
to heave upwards i gotta run out of time
after several tugs techno gym broke free
leaving one foot and one leg behind
great i have that now
kyle glanced at the attendant who was
staring bewildered and ran outside great
okay is it time for the interview i
think
isn't it isn't it time for the interview
oh it's time for the interview
kyle hurried to the set her normal he
ceased to be a ghost before he arrived
um
sitting across from his host chair was a
glamorous woman with an air of genuinity
okay
as kyle approached her rachel looked up
and smiled okay rachel's smile quickly
turned to shock as she realized kyle had
not put on clothes that day ah that's a
problem or is it kyle waved and smiled
broadly rachel uncomfortably averted her
eyes okay kyle started making his rounds
around the room greeting each crew
member none of whom looked at him
directly great
as it became apparent that kyle had no
intention of leaving rachel made some
excuses and exited the set okay one by
one the crew followed suit ah just a
little nudity is that much of a bother i
thought we lived in the 21st century
kyle was left all alone okay
oh
prepared by me
all right well that's
if there's a hundred and seventeen
endings to this i imagine that the
majority of them involve you being
clothed
all right i'm gonna get out of bed or
i'm not i'm not [ __ ] around here open
the closet choose an outfit kyle decided
to take some time to choose the perfect
outfit knowing how important appearance
is
god skunk pasty
kyle chose the pasties made out of
mashed skunk flesh
getting the slimy garments to stay
proved difficult so kyle opted to stick
them to his body with hot glue
what's that sound oh it's in the game oh
weird
okay well that's good sit at the desk
uh checking drawer
small key wait that's important
that's important for the thing i forget
which wha what it was in the pantry
i feel like it was in the pantry right
notes kyle wrote down his first question
that's your mother mother
kyle wrote down his second question
kyle wrote down his third question
not that one that one
[Music]
oh god kyle wrote down his last question
are you guilty
kyle ripped his page
out of the notebook and got up from the
desk oh my god okay all right jeez oh
all right back to the room i gotta go to
the hallway
kitchen pantry
the pantry door lock creaked as if it
hadn't moved for years but eventually
opened great instead of an assortment of
canned goods and grains kyle's pantry
stored his massive amount of bottled
lard as much as i would love to chug a
bottle of lard i feel like i'm gonna
need that for the interview
kyle grabbed a bottle of lard and
stashed it on his person for later use
anyway i'm ready for this goddamn i'm
going to open the box kyle open the
fridge intending to find something to
eat how about a nice breakfast
kyle constructed a breakfast of poached
eggs and toast along with a small fruit
cup and grilled sausage smell smash
smash hmm smashed his breakfast to a
pulp using both fists
oh yeah
okay all right
i'll go now
i don't have time for anything do i it's
the interview time kyle okay sitting
across from his ho
okay good evening kyle she said looking
him in the eyes i've been looking
forward to being here great do you like
my pasties would you like some lard
kyle responded
god man don't make me do these things
don't make me scream and spin in a
circle surely that's not what i want to
do
kyle stretched his arms wide tilted his
neck upwards and
was interrupted by his producer telling
him and rachel that it was time to start
the show no no
i insist kyle shoved his producer out of
the way spread his arms wide and began
to scream loudly of course i did
he began to rotate slowly screaming
throughout lightly brushing his hands
against the faces of rachel and his
producer
this is a gentle
slightest brush
after several minutes kyle was finished
he slowly put his hands to his sides and
smiled of course i did he did not me
i'm not kyle
i'm ready said kyle
[Laughter]
rachel blinked at kyle shrugged and
walked over to her seat i mean i guess
there's no better warm-up right he
puts people right at ease the moment
after seating the studio lights
brightened and the cameras clicked on
okay here we go
good evening everyone said kyle looking
at the camera welcome back to stay up
late with kyle okay
tonight i have the pleasure of
interviewing the lovely rachel may who
needs no more introduction and i will
say no more
kyle motioned a rachel who smiled and
waved at the camera hello kyle she said
i'm glad to be here you won't be would
you like some lard
in response kyle collapsed on the floor
oh i didn't need anything today from a
combination of stressful preparation and
not eating anything kyle it passed out i
tried
nobody in the studio quite knew what to
do with him they began to poke kyle in
the back to see if he moved uh-huh
after a while they ended the broadcast
shut off the lights and went home how
long did they film me on the ground
passed out how long kyle was left
face-first on the floor great
that's great prepared by starving
himself okay well if the basic [ __ ]
is that i have to prepare
this is gonna this is gonna be okay
hey hold on a second hang on i'm gonna
check and drawer get the small key
yeah i know right kyle is your mother a
mother ever eaten a rock do you ever
smile are you guilty and then i get out
of here and then i go to the hallway and
i move to the kitchen and i took the
pantry unlocked and then i looked in i
grabbed a lard and i go back and i open
the fridge and i prepare breakfast and i
eat it kyle ate his breakfast slowly and
thoughtfully enjoying every bite i'm not
enjoying those invites
[Music]
okay whatever man okay return return to
hallway
leave apartment visit tech store
steel techno gym
i've got him
and i'm ready
here we go
here we go approaching rachel i
approached
i'm approaching lord
guilty
what
i forgot to put on clothes god damn it i
open the closet i choose an outfit it's
tasty time i get back i sit at my desk i
check in drawer get the key go back
write notes mother egg smile guilty
back to room the hallway kitchen pantry
unlocked look grab lard back open
breakfast eat
[Music]
i'm still gonna scream yeah i insist
well i'm sure we'll have a lot to
discuss so we might as well dive right
in said kyle dive right into this lard
dive right into this bottle that is kyle
pulled out his bottle of lard bit the
top off and chugged it
yes i did
kyle's body you rejected the lard to
spew chunks of lard and digestive fluid
in every direction well that doesn't
seem like what i expected everything
within a 10-foot radius was immediately
covered including rachel great
kyle continued to vomit
okay rachel bravely fought to stay
seated amidst the vomit hoping to save
the show from disaster disaster it's
going great
unfortunately kyle's vomit had covered
all of the cameras there was no
broadcast
kyle finished spewing eventually then
okay the broadcast was not recoverable
all present were sent home to try again
another day
as kyle got home he made a mental note
to refill his lard supply good call kyle
kyle consumed
how many how many goddamn all right here
we go with her away because i want to
scavenge kyle quickly gossip there we go
all right well more there was that's
enough i'm gonna sit at my desk i'm
gonna check in the drawer i'm gonna get
the key
i'm bringing this goddamn lard there's a
reason there's a reason here kyle wants
to unlock look
grab lard back open
breakfast eat it i'm good baby
kyle hurry to the set i didn't get
clothed
ah
okay all right okay i'm a nudist okay
exit open the closet choosing outside
skunk
this is the best i'm just going to
check he kyle
is there something else there
a sordid chain kyle scooped up okay i
have change you might
egg smile
guilty always kitchen i'm gonna not get
the lard this time always
leave
tech store
my batteries would change i got i'll
count it out one dollar and
i got it i have batteries now i don't
know what that means
and i as well rachel answered kyle
extending his hand and greeting you are
a most welcome guest great
after other mild exchanges of
pleasantries kyle and rachel were
prompted to take their places for the
broadcast okay
a moment after seating this uh-huh good
evening okay introduce more kyle motion
more
more i'm very ready said rachel with a
winning smile it's time
kyle produced the notes he had taken
earlier
you ever even raw egg hole hey rachel
ever eaten a raw egg hole asked kyle
ever
um like shell and all asked
kyle continued i had like a lot
it's really bad though so sometimes i
spit it back up okay
there was a silence
it actually gets easier the more you do
it continued kyle without losing
momentum so don't start i say
rachel chose not to answer and looked in
another direction uh that's why i give
these hard-hitting questions kyle asked
another question
so said kyle my mother is a mother my
mother's mother is her mother and my
mother's mother
and many mothers have mother's mother's
mother is your mother a mother
rachel went to answer and stopped
i believe she said eventually
that i should answer
yes
kyle asked another question
do you ever smile smack kyle like
seriously
rachel stop smiling
if you're gonna be on the show you need
to smile okay
said kyle not smiling
you're here to get views and you'll get
more views if you smile here i'll show
you how
kyle turned to the camera and gave the
audience a huge teeth clenched bug-eyed
grimace
rachel nodded and obviously wanted to
move on man i'd be a great late-night
host i'd be the best
kyle asked another question
are you guilty rachel
are you guilty kyle threw his questions
on the floor stood up and pointed at her
rachel's eye twitched slightly guilty of
what dear kyle she smiled disingenuously
i knew it
guilty spat kyle of your crimes
excellent
rachel did not answer her eyelids both
started twitching uncontrollably
after reading his final question kyle
looked up from his paper
oh okay
all right well rachel he said i think
that's all i was planning on asking you
oh okay good
if that's the case kyle may i ask you
something in return you can try rachel's
smiling one more time i can't guarantee
what the results are gonna be
what on earth are you wearing are they
made of skunks
absolutely
before kyle could answer the camera shut
down the broadcast was over what a good
show
kyle returned home knowing the interview
had gone well it sure did
but as he lay in bed and drifted to
sleep he felt that perhaps
something was still missing yeah what
the hell uh was any of the batteries for
oh
kyle prepared very well
did i
are you sure about that what did i
unlock more world options what does that
even mean
oh my god oh my god i don't even know
wait there there's like different
scenarios okay so if i get uh so if i
get the key i unlock a different
scenario kyle woke up
skip
wait a minute a new world what does that
even mean
maybe get the full version
i have the full version
don't i oh
do i not am i playing the demo or
something what is happening
i'm very confused
i only have the free i have the free
free
hang on hang on hold on guys well i
didn't even know that i had the free
edition wait hang on it seemed as though
i didn't have that
what do i already have complete edition
i do have wait a minute complete edition
right there i already have it but i have
it
i have it
this is complete edition this is the
only one i have the thing
no
no no
i have it
i have the thing well this is being a
bit of a [ __ ]
the hell is that
what is this
this is different
what is happening
there's music now
i'm so confused
i'm gonna wither away kyle shucks
i'm gonna scavenge grease resources comb
through the damp piles of filth and mold
on his floor in search of helpful items
okay after finding and eating a few bits
of crumbs and old cheese kyle found
something much more important
indeed it was the corpse of harry a
friend that had gone missing years ago
while at kyle's house
kyle was glad to see him again but was
unsure of whether to interrupt such an
important day with harry business i deal
with harry kyle hoisted harry onto his
shoulder and took him outside okay kyle
began dragging harry's body down the
street drawing many many stairs it's
okay i'm a ghost kyle knew exactly where
he needed to take harry's corpse on a
lovely playdate just the two of them
just yeah kyle and harry started at the
arcade kyle used harry's arms to operate
the joysticks and push buttons
after five or six different games the
two friends had enough tickets for a
single candy bar great
they took their prize to the local park
for eating okay kyle tried to feed some
of the chocolate bar to harry but harry
seemed to not have an appetite i can
flip the pen after eating kyle noticed a
nearby playground he dragged harry over
okay
kyle tried to figure out a way to swing
harry onto the swing set but lacking the
ability to grip harry kept falling out
all right instead kyle started to lug
harry to the top of the slide and shove
him down time and time again ah that's
fun finally kyle took carrie to the
movies to see as many popular films as
their pocket change aloud that's
adorable kyle quickly found that he had
no pocket change so he searched through
harry's pockets until he found his
wallet
okay kyle bought two tickets to a love
romance after getting inside kyle left
harry to go find a restroom by the time
kyle had finished using the restroom he
had forgotten that he brought harry
along oh kyle watched a love romance by
himself harry's corpse sat on a bench in
the atrium oh kyle is kind of a dick and
also this is strange because it's corpse
while crosstalk was in the movie a
beautiful thing happened okay
harry's corpse imbued with the power of
friendship and love
was reanimated wow and probably pissed
off harry's old rotten flesh gained
color and life his fingernails regrew
his missing eye came back okay
by the time the movie was over harry was
able to greet kyle with a large friendly
hug as his old self
kyle was confused but delighted to have
his long-lost friend meet him on his way
out of the theater
the two made plans to get drinks
together and parted ways for the day
great kyle returned home forgetting
about the interview with rachel oh [ __ ]
[Music]
well that's nice and i have a new cursor
apparently and i'm still in the free
edition
oh
[Music]
nice
i like it
but also
herman the free edition i'll help the
knoll oh that's so sweet
that's so sweet i'm gonna end this one
here because i unfortunately seem to be
stuck on the free edition i'm very
confused but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to play this for yourself i'll
leave a link in the description uh lots
of potential choices here lots of uh
lots of laughs to be out of actually
that was very funny but uh that's enough
for me you try to get all 117 endings if
you dare but thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought in the comments below check out
the games that i played in the
description playlist and as always i
will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
bye